donc c'est incontestable être une star
vous apporte une longue liste davantage
qui vous permettent de vivre heureux
mais avec le succès arrive aussi son lot
de déconvenues c'est l'amère expérience
à laquelle meghan markle est en train de
goûter depuis qu'elle est passée du
statut de starlette d'une série télé à
épouser d'un prince d'angleterre si elle
devait se douter que son couple avec le
prince harry ferait parler elle ne
pensait certainement pas que la pression
des paparazzis la pousserait à s'exiler
au canada
aujourd'hui les deux amoureux ne compte
pas se laisser gâcher leur nouvelle vie
par cette même presse qui semble une
fois encore bien décidé à ne rien
manquer de ce bonheur loin de buckingham
palace
à peine arrivé au canada le couple a
d'ores et déjà prévenu la presse people
qui ne tolérerait aucun dérapage de leur
part et le couple a raison de se méfier
car les dérapages liés à la chasse au
scoop frôle parfois les limites du
macabre en 2014 une personne
malveillante aurait capturer des photos
du champion de formule 1 michael
schumacher alors dans le coma après le
terrible accident de ski dont il a été
victime des photos macabres qui aurait
ensuite été vendu 1 million de livres
sterling à la presse britannique
mais suite à la pression que la famille
et la justice serait exercé ces photos
n'ont heureusement jamais été publié des
méthodes qui interroge sur les limites
de la presse people alors chasse au
scoop atteinte à la vie privée et
dérapages les paparazzis vont-ils trop
loin
les photos volées de michael schumacher
1 d'hercule 17 millions d'euros prise à
son domicile ça c'est ça franchement
rangement c'est inadmissible ça pour
vous ou pas est-ce que les paparazzi
vont trop loin je vous montrais d'autres
images parce que on a des images aussi
qui montre un qui montre que les
nouveaux voisins dari et mégane sont
plutôt contre la présence des paparazzi
qui cherche par tous les moyens
d'approché aussi la nouvelle maison du
coup que ça veut dire que même
l'entourage et vraiment je vous dis est
polluée par ce qui se passe autour des
stars regarde beaucoup de papas radicova
l'extérieur de la maison en utilisant
deux grands téléobjectif pour essayer
d'obtenir des clichés de l'intérieur de
la maison évaluée à 14 millions de
dollars
beaucoup de locaux ne veulent pas
participer au jeu des paparazzi un
loueur de bateaux a refusé de
transporter des paparazzi qui lui
offrait 150 $ de l'heure pour les
emmener faire des photos devant la
maison point chara ça pourrait être un
business très lucratif mais le plus
important est de garder la conscience
tranquille
le mouvement les locaux veulent défendre
la vie privée de la jeune femme alors
benjamin castaldi est ce que les
paparazzis contrôlons à bois bien sûr je
suis vivant beaucoup trop loin et depuis
depuis très très longtemps que lui
disait de l'année rappelez-vous il a
quand même photographié le fils de romy
schneider
voilà en mort ça fait des années que ça
se fait on en a parlé avec mathieu sur
les missions qu'on a fait ensemble ils
qu'elle fait des photos qu'on n'avait
pas diffusé de lady di enfin volonté
dans sa voiture enfin pour moi ils vont
beaucoup trop loin après c'est un jeu de
chat et de souris très bien mais moi ça
m'a pourri vraiment la vie quand j'ai
trouvé avec ray vit avec moi j'ai dit
moi j'ai tout mangé
alors voici d'abord l'humiliation côté
vous photographier à poil c'est sur la
balle et ce à cause de mon petit jeu là
quand ils vous prennent voilà en
situation cfc à ses millions et après
quand ils vous prennent pendant que vous
jouez avec vos enfants et qui détourne
moi ça m'avait fait un mal de chien
parce qu'il a si c'était pas ça en fait
gt gt avec flavie sur la plage et je
joue avec mon fils enzo le dernier et je
les prie par le pied comme ça et comme
on était sur la plage et qu'avant on
l'année on avait bu un verre de rosé
ils ont assimilé les dans des emballages
il est tellement bourrés qui fait du mal
à son enfant ça avait avant sa bonne
habitude tu dis que tu viens de boire et
que ton fils comme c'est un con tu fais
exprès mais non jamais qu'est ce que tu
veux te dire
ça l'avait cédée c'était parfois tu
étais tu vas trop loin je te veel ou jeu
mais non je t'explique tu prend l'apéro
non mais tu fais rire tu trouve ça drôle
jamais sim et une idée qu'on a épuisé
son enfant vient jamais ça me fait de la
peine
je viens de jalopnik vu les ai pris mon
nom j'ai pas dit ça
non mais quand tu vois qu'il a pris son
fils près de bouteilles montage mais
trop pris par lui sur la plage tu as un
verre de rosé à la main avant ils font
la photo ça se verrait aussi ce coin est
bref et après tu que tu joues et on
envoie futé francs par les enfants ça
m'a fait de la peine à le comprendre
sophie ce qui est extrêmement choquant
sont les sommes en fait qu'ils sont
induites danse dans ce genre de
photographier c'est à dire que là il ya
plus d'un million d'euros je crois pour
la photo de schumann c'est la course au
scoop
les mecs veulent absolument avoir la
photographie on sera je vois mon cours
de l'or noir
on se souvient à la charge du gros
pactole qui avait été promis à celui qui
allait prendre mazarine en photo avec
son père dans la rue un jour et c'est
vrai que ça ouvre la porte aujourd'hui
puisque finalement s'intéresse plus aux
histoires de fesses des politiques qu'à
leur vie puis alors vous dites non à gia
jalil photos de moi avec une fille avec
qui j'étais qui voulait pas forcément
que ça se sache
voilà donc c'est vrai que c'est lui a
porté préjudice voilà mais moi je trouve
que c'est d'une hypocrisie totale voilà
ce qu'il faut à un moment faut être en
accord avec nos paroles avec les actes
le jour où ce camp-là arrêtera d'acheter
quand ils prennent le train le voit ci
ou ceux des magazines populaires qui
montrent des photos de paparazzi et ben
là je serais d'accord avec vous bah moi
j'en achète dont je veux pas que les
jeunes me régale les photos volées
je ne peux pas gueuler quand ils font
des photos sur moi moi j'ai un moment
j'ai par exemple j'étais entre le foie
gras et bien c'était pour la première
fois ce que je pense au lavallois pour
la preuve fast and and white n'est pas
bon que j'ai vraiment fait un accord
arrêtée acheter des magazines des
magazines populaires people alors on a
on a on a on arrive à bien voyez
l'exemple pour dire qu'ils vont trop
loin de tout le monde prend cet exemple
c'est lady di la tournée puisque le soir
de l'accident de voiture qui a tué diana
une thèse explique que sa voiture
roulait extrêmement vite pour échapper
aux paparazzi réagissait là dessus parce
qu'ils vont trop loin ou pas bah oui
visiblement cet accident a eu lieu alors
que la voiture était poursuivi par un
certain nombre de photographes de la
presse à scandale les paparazzi comme on
dit en italien
l'état de la voiture témoigne de la
violence extrême du choc la puissante
mercedes était lancé à pleine vitesse
dans le tunnel de l'alma en plein paris
vers zéro heure trente sans doute plus
de 150 kilomètres pour fausser compagnie
aux paparazzi qui les suivaient à moto
le chauffeur aurait alors décidé de
rouler très vite trop vite alors mathieu
oui je me sers des mesures que si on a
fait un documentaire dessus et ça ne
fait pas rire d'abord rien ne justifie
rien qu'on roule à 150 dans paris même
quand on est des paparazzi au fait si
peur des enfants des scooters et des
machins donc les paparazzis n'ont pas
tué les dédits et quand on est une
personnalité comme les didier consorts
mercedes d'un hôtel comme le crillon
pardon on a des papes avec un chauffeur
koné g surtout on est une semaine déjà
c'est une connerie autre chose pardon où
il est pas grâce aux paparazzi j'ai
quand même appris comment président
avait une femme qui est une fille fuit
par donc zappé mazarine pingeot ton
entretenait j'ai appris que notre
président effectivement aussi avait un
cancer était malade avait fait un
deuxième mandat et que peut-être il
n'aurait pas pu diriger le pays
j'ai appris que nicholas abbey 0 pardon
oui j'ai appris que nicolas sarkozy
avait auparavant c'est à disney avait
changé de femmes également à tout ça oui
je dirai aussi que françois lord livrer
des couacs françois mais voilà que
françois hollande qui avait dit je serai
le normal jeu sera normal à l'intense
coûté près de damas le droit de savoir
des choses ces gens là aujourd'hui je le
dis je me fais insulter aujourd'hui ces
gens là aujourd'hui font du vrai
journalisme
alors évidemment quand c'est pour mon
train ça sur la plage et tout ça ou un
bouton bond c'est rigolo mais ça j'avoue
c'est pas très méchant mais en revanche
échoué dès lors comme un légume à
l'heure quant à schumacher je me dirais
c'est quelque chose qui est peut-être
très noble aucun journal pour le moment
je vous le dis ne lâcherai t na chn/n
usinage qu'ils vont acheter des images
il ya des fans de schumacher pour le
moment qu'ils sont en train d'essayer de
retrouver ceux qui ont fait les photos
mais pour les lyncher et pour le moment
personne parce que je peux vous dire que
des photos in et quelques-unes notamment
à l'hôtel là pendant l'hôtel à l'hôpital
pour les modèles sébastien vallier la
lra théorie paparazzi pardon l'état dans
lequel il est évidemment on s'en doute
bien après huit ans il a plus de muscles
il est perdu 40 kilos c'est pas la
personne qu'on veut vous
yuna des photos qui ont traîné personne
ne veut les acheter donc la presse
people pardon elle est bien plus propre
que certains autres magazines la mémoire
courte il ya dix ans je n'ai pas fait
flasher sur une plage avec les
personnalités ne suis personne ne s'en
fout moi
l'animateur connu des choses qu'il ya
des choses qui gênent mais on la demi
heure
vous étiez photographes avec un
animateur connu je crois que vous dire
même le montant que j'ai touché que tj
grant alors dites nous tout c'est
toucher 16000 euros 7000 euros parce que
vous avez attaqué parce que j'avais
attaqué effectivement j'ai touché 16000
euros
parce que c'était la première fois qu'on
considérait que c'était de la outings
c'était la première fois qu'un magazine
est en fait pour tout vous dire
closer avait sorti l'histoire politique
avec ségolène royal et du coup voici
voulu faire un gros coup et pauvres
derrière s'est dit tiens on va vous ces
quelques heures j'étais avec un
animateur très connu on était à broche
n'était qu'un animateur très connue
c'est vrai que ça vous a ajouté exemple
ajouté
et pour vous dire la vérité j'étais si
vous en train d g avec ma soeur et je
vois cette semaine un euro lyonnais
neuro 20 voici machin au matin non alors
nous branle bas de combat j'appelle ma
pauvre homme ma grand mère qui était
chez elle il a fallu planqué tous les
magazines parce qu'on lui emmener le
samedi tous les magazines sont en
auxiliaires de vie lui en est elle
savait pas que j'étais gay ni rien mais
tout ça pour vous dire que là c'est
parce que yoann outing doivent alors
être trop loin le cas des people pardon
comme toi benjamin comme moi et ça vous
a pas vous laisser on n'est rien on
n'est rien ou mois pour moi c'est quand
c'est des vrais vrai qu'à comme
schumacher comme la politique bah ça m'a
blessée elle est horrible
imaginez mais vous avez le lendemain
saine et des mauges a touché combien
vous au plus à moi j'ai le bac + moi non
mais comment vous aviez touchée à
l'époque pour ça j'aime bien moi j'ai
pas grand chose parce que comme moi le
poids que vous voulez la vérité c'est
quoi c'est que quand on est connu
moi avec flavie j'ai fait le choix de
faire des photos - fois veut on a fait
des photos de famille enceinte en effet
des photos la maison fera donc quand
vous donnez
et quand vous ouvrez votre maison
derrière quand vous attaquez n'est pas
grand chose et c'est très normal et
c'est très normal moi aujourd'hui à
temps je n'attaque plus vous avez touché
16000 euros
lorsque vous avez dit il faut toujours
toujours toujours quoiqu'il arrive même
c'est sinik rohff auto attaque et
marketing sinon effectivement ensuite au
tribunal de nanterre où ailleurs ou dire
alors quand ça vous arrange vous
attaquez pas et quand ça vous arrange
vous attaquer moi j'ai toujours toujours
attaquer une fois juge et 5000 euros
avec une pub en toucher du tout chez moi
dans ma carrière peut-être 40000 euros
jean grenet s'est énormément d'argent
énormément d'argent mais croyez moi les
16000 je m'en serais bien passé parce
que
on perd ça sera ma grand mère ne savait
pas et mes amis savaient pas et juste
pour vous dire les photos de schumacher
à n'ont pas été vendus en france mais
elles ont été vendues à l'étranger 1
millions d'euros
oui parce que nous en france on a un
arsenal juridique les journaux les gens
peuvent se défendre attaquer et toucher
de l'argent ce n'est pas le cas à
l'étranger où les lois d'anthologie que
sont la presse n'existe pas mon style
unique vous dites mauvaise moi j'ai vu
naître je suis pas choqué j'ai vu naître
cette presse donc j'ai vu des artistes
qui jusque-là en profiter largement qui
sont dit merde
maintenant on peut être choqué et vous
savez pas mais qu'il s'est rendu compte
qu ont évolué et que les paparazzi sa
lettre obsolète s'est passé un patrick
bruel parce que joe hill et à roland
garros il s'est d'abord il partage
il avait quelqu'un le choper avec un
portable il a compris instantanément que
salle est bien plus grave que les trucs
de paparazzi parce que les photos de
portable elle poste à balancer n'importe
qui n'importe comment même sans qu'ils
puissent réagir ce qu'on voulait nous
dire mathieu c'est un président aussi
qui m'a choqué quand vous avez sur
instagram de leonardo dicaprio
ce n'est que de l'écologie ces discours
que de l'écologie c'est monsieur
gentleman est un célèbre paparazzi que
je ne nommerai pas l'a suivi pendant ses
vacances en thaïlande
ce lyon qui l'a suivi il était dans une
chambre à 42000 euros ce que je vous dis
est vrai entouré gonzesses il est arrivé
en jet privé il avait loué un yacht je
pense que chaque qt tue 5 enfants par
jour et ce type s'était yacht jet bière
dans des hôtels
donc c est l inverse de ce qu'ils
prônaient absolument cette presse là
même blanche gardin on a fait une blague
cette presse-là comme voilà nous nous
retrouvons un petit peu la vérité il est
bien gentil dicaprio et donne des
grandes leçons devant un micro avec une
larme à l'oeil
mais la vérité il a des yachts des jets
et qu'il n'a rien à [ __ ] de l'écologie
je vis amis à une déontologie du
paparazzi à une noblesse du paradis pour
moi c'est pour ça que je suis pas du
tout choqué les grands paparazzi ce sont
des enquêteurs
il plante pendant quinze jours dans des
fourgons moi j'en ai connu un trois
semaines dans un fourgon pour avoir une
photo il a planqué dans des arbres et si
et si nos politiques étaient
transparents parce que ce qui fait
l'événement aujourd'hui ce sont les
révélations sur les politiques s'il
était transparent et s'il y avait un
accord entre leurs paroles et leurs
actes
il y aurait pas besoin de photos
détournées c'est une sorte de système et
pour moi c'est vrai je suis assez
d'accord avec mathieu parfois c'est
presque du journaliste d'investigation
qui remplace que les journalistes ne
font de l'elysée
c'est devenu la nouvelle paparazzi à
part ouf c'est drôle devrait arrêter
voici ils écrivent que d'eads a alors
complètement fou alors été là pour moi
mais combien de voici et un torchon raté
annonce sophie mars après qu'il ait un
tel machin machin combat une fois c'est
faux bref pas très sensible on s'est
tous regardés nous nous annoncer ça
qu'on a mis le truc sur nous c'était
toujours fous j'ai amélioré mes est
encore l arctique ya deux semaines
qu'ils étaient annoncés plein de trucs
selon une aura une source tout et vous
vous êtes en bisbille avec eux pas du
tout je connais pas je n'ai rien contre
eux en plus je m'en fous totalement à
bercy je vous dire alors oui nos
résultats donc la question c'est s'ils
vont trop loin et tu parles de
mitterrand mitterrand il a donné
l'autorisation il a même convoqué les
photographes et le thé parce que c'est
le patron paris match qui me l'a dit
donc parfois tu dis des grosses bêtes ne
dit pas les grosses bêtises et aider
claude rien ne leur est trop loin c'est
quoi c'est la vexer des sources évoquées
jeu est trop loin c'est quand on dépasse
les banques quand une photographie
lequel de cadavres de deux d'un voile à
d'un enfant lavéra trop loin de schumann
on n'a pas entendu non mais en fait moi
aussi je suis du côté du nom et en même
temps du oui parce qu'effectivement sur
les autoroutes les gens ils ralentissent
et regard de son efficacement pas
paradis c'est ça en fait on regarde
l'accident regarde le drame on regarde
l'obscène en garde le groupe you on est
grand on ne peut pas et on arrive
malheureusement on a tout ça en nous
malheureusement voilà et je vais faire
un petit coup un petit point d'histoire
parce que vous adorez histoire oui
j'adore vous savez d'où ça vient le mot
paparazzi bat pas la fin évita décennies
avait un personnage qui suivait
mastroianni qui est un photographe et
donc ces deux mots c'est papatakis et
les petits moustiques et razza c'est
vive lumière et donc même pas au
quotidien qu'on avance à l'égard team
aussi que c'est très désagréable comme
les paparazzi et ça fait des lumières
comme les flashs qui crépitent
heureusement la roue mais regardez alors
qu'un poste les téléspectateurs s'il
vous plaît oui à 87% bien sûr